You know, when you meet someone and you don't know anything about them,
so you're a little leery of them, and, like,
sometimes a Google search is not enough.
Like, you're like, ugh,
I wanna know more. That's where Public Data check comes in.
I use Public Data check. You can do a reverse phone number lookup.
I love that. You can look for offenders in your area.
So you can enter your address,
and it will tell you in your whole area.
It will give you their picture,
their whole crime history,
what they've been convicted of there at, like,
Unit A. Like,
this apartment complex, unit A.
As a single mom, and I don't have a lot of, like,
family or, like,
people around, I.
I truly do want every little thing I can have
that's gonna make me feel safer
or informed or whatever.
And I absolutely love public data check.
Like, absolutely love it.
If I know you know that I have put your name in there,
and I know everything I need to know about you.
I have a link in my bio if you want to use it, because I.
I'm here for it.